vous aime pas et n'aura tacle les
chroniqueurs de tpm paix dans salut les
terriens
alors on va voir l'extrait vous benjamin
je vous aimais isabelle vous n'aimez pas
une minute trente juste après on regarde
alors il ya trois semaines il est
retourné sur le plateau de touche pas à
mon poste et vous allez donner un
conseil aux chroniqueurs leur avait dit
profitez-en car vous êtes grassement
payés à rien [ __ ]
alors ça pas toujours été le cas mais
c'est vrai qu'on travaille assez peu on
va pas se mentir il ya eu une période on
travaille beaucoup on décrétait beaucoup
les émissions et comme là c'est devenu
beaucoup du divertissement
c'est vrai qu'ils sont payés un peu à
rigoler aux vans de papa ouais
tant mieux mais c'est vrai je leur ai
dit voilà profiter quand même les
enfants j'ai eu la vie de kelly en off
voilà c'est très baba et nous et des
justes les séries c'est vrai que juste
pour répondre et nous c'est vrai qu'on a
jamais autant décrypter les émissions
que là ce moment donc c'est vrai que ça
faisait longtemps peut-être qu'elle nous
a regardés benjamin vous aimez et c'est
noir elle attend d'avoir gelé commencer
par savoir écrire des mots rejeté par
scanner les cartes j'avais la cgt
passant oui oui j'aime
c'était pas du tout ma meilleure amie
j'ai appris à la connaître et à
découvrir
elle a fait elle a fait une boutade aly
fall dit la vérité elle dès qu'on a une
place en or qu'on est effectivement à la
télévision tous les jours on
effectivement rémunérés pour ça que
c'est pas le bagne quoi pour moi pas à
l'usiné bref condé voilà après certains
travaillent plus que d'autres enfin
c'est vrai mais bon les mots jean michel
maire je connais vraiment si c'est bien
une personne que je connais un peu aussi
ce temps sur ce bateau c'est honnorat et
elle n'a pas dit ça pour quoi
c'est vraiment cessé même pas pour faire
le buzz à lumière une chose je vais vous
l'a dit d'ailleurs sur le plateau
voilà l année sur le plateau et elle a
raison il faut pas se vanter on n'est
pas à l'usiné on a un travail
merveilleux et voilà ce que voulait il
s'appelle vous n'aimez pas mais il
absolument pas question de ça et moi je
n'aurais n'aura tu le sais je n'attaque
pas du tout la jeune femme que j'irai
voir à l'automne au théâtre mais en
revanche c'est le message qu'on désirait
pas bougé
le message que ça envoie 14 parce que
réellement des gens france mais peut
être grassement payés à ne rien [ __ ]
alors tant mieux cela m'aidera c'est un
nom tant grassement payés non à ne rien
[ __ ] non tant mieux si c'est ton
câblage ah mince mais c'est pas le mien
c'était ne sais pas le cas de maxime ce
pas le cas de christine c'est pas le cas
de gilles il balançait beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
le truc global qui est de dire mais tout
ce qu'ils nous foutent rien et ils sont
grassement l'oeil et moi je saurai vous
a convaincu parce que là c'est vrai que
voilà c'est vite parce que voilà en plus
isabelle elle est découpée sentez-vous
prêt si vous n'aimez pas du tout non
pour moi j'ai une règle dans la vie ne
jamais cracher dans la soupe travaille
pas dans la soupe s'ils crachent dans la
soupe ebit deuxième déçu par les crises
dans trois premières deuxièmement non je
pense pas je pense qu'on travaille je
pense qu'on décrit parfois moi je passe
la journée quand même regarder des
émissions que je connaissais pas avant
donc s'il y en a qui ont été vexés dit
l'américain jb oui j'ai été très blessé
d'autant que j'apprécie beaucoup et
nohra c'est pas bien de dire ça
effectivement c'est cracher dans la
soupe
je trouve que c'est méchant c'est un peu
dans mon vieux mais je n'ai pris comme
tel
j'ai été blessé c'est le mot gelé très
mal vécu en plus c'est faux on peut
travailler sérieusement sans se prendre
au sérieux mais on bosse quand même
voilà
mais regarde la remercie bernard est le
royaume des amis là vous là quand elle
est arrivée les sapeurs arrêté on devait
demander d'où cette s'est mise à parler
les autres paysages bernard parce que je
suis désolé je crois qu'elle parle
d'elle moi je travaille ici j'aurai
beaucoup j'avais oui ça se verra quand
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
donc ça m'a pas fait plaisir parce que
je désolé non du travail
on est heureux d'être là certes mon
travail alors oui le clem pas je suis
étonné bah je trouve qu'elle a fait du
hainaut et j'adore et et n'aura donc a
été généreuse
je pense que c'est plutôt les questions
de tir à des soins qu'ils étaient un
petit peu orienté et ouais donc elle a
fait le show qui retire ne va pas se
mentir il y là voilà il assure voici
aussi mais voilà les cerveaux dans le
texte de thé chauffe fait le show comme
d'habitude mais c'est quoi le temps
d'accord avec benjamin on n'est pas
laminé tout mais par contre faut arrêter
de faire croire que on est tous des
feignasses c'est aussi un métier et ça
serait même insultant pour vous ça veut
dire que vous payez des gens inutilement
mais ça me fait plaisir mais je me sens
bien
jésus m ouais parce qu'en fait moi je
connais moins enora malagré que vous
mais je trouve que ça correspond à 100
c'est ça aussi c'est des poils à gratter
les brute de décoffrage ce sens voilà
donc elle et elle fait pas dans la
nuance dont moi ça m'a pas ça m'a pas
spécialement choqué vous n'avez pas à
vous ouais je pense qu'on put on connaît
une aura et moi pour l'aimer pour les
raisons pour lesquelles benjamin a aimé
moi c'est les mêmes raisons qui ont fait
que j'ai pas aimé
ekwalla dix rebelles et c'est à dire que
effectivement hainaut a le sentiment que
on est ici autour de la table à faire un
peu juste a rigolé alors qu'elle sait
très bien de l'intérieur que on attrape
un travail est en fait effectivement je
pense qu'elle a dû cependant bout de
quatre 4 heures de tournage il avait
fini par lui faire dire ce que je viens
d'entendre la bande à pyla vous n'avez
pas non parce que je trouve ça un peu
rédhibitoire pour les autres et puis en
plus elle se permet de dire ça alors
qu'elle n'y travaille plus pour quoi
elle ne disait pas ça quand elle
travaillait ici
voilà c'est un peu maintenant que je me
suis barré bah voilà vous êtes on était
tous payés à rien faire mais quand tu
étais là tu sais très bien la pression
que c'est très bien que parfois ils ont
regardé l'émission c'est très bien qu'il
faut chercher des arguments il ya des
trucs que tu sais pas par forcément et
il faut s'exprimer correctement fin bref
rien que ça c'est quand les pieds au
delà du boulot on peut prendre l'exemple
concret de enora je pense qu'elle l'a
dit dans l'interview que c'était
caricaturé par moments elle sait aussi
qu'elle s'est pris plein de tacle sur
les réseaux sociaux et tout c'est aussi
le prix à payer quand tu es chroniqueur
mais ça fait aussi partie du boulot mais
c'est vrai que ça fait partie du boulot
c c'est compliqué pour eux les gens mais
je crois pas qu'il y ait ça méchamment
voilà ce qu'a dit que ce tampon soit
effectivement elle l'avait dit
si elle l'avait dit ici savait pas trop
choquer les personnes autour de la table
on avait plus rigoler mais vous aimez ou
pas peu importe la somme concernée je
suis pas chroniqueuse en aoc pour vous
je suis là pour la d'arcade
[Rires]